hello everybody and welcome back to
let's play cry of fear okay as in an
attempt to not waste you guys it's time
I'm gonna read little comment here you
are an awesome person XD yeah I sub just
recently and I'm looking forward to your
new videos also to get to the next part
in the story the door you came out of
from the mind maze you go back through
there back to the training put the fuses
there I hope this helps XD Thank You Val
1 to 102 also ghost 5 to 3 1 said
something similar he said you need to
put these fuses in the tunnel near that
train but someone else replied to him I
hope he reads this loving LP but I can't
say I'm a fan of his episodes when Mark
is lost and running in circles EA us 1
is that some sass I hear ok think it was
a bitch-ass okay so I'll go back to here
I really just fell over
I know do I go back here thank you who's
in here right I'm gonna get lost anyway
no matter what you try to do to help me
I'm gonna get lost I even bother
now right here yeah yeah okay I guess I
should have tried to go down here in the
beginning anyway Oh want some oh look
okay Google ooh that's a big ladder come
on get down there get down on it
Hey look at this
teamwork high-five boom bottom it's
awfully quiet like this
Oh Oh who's there who's there hello
Oh alrighty
oh really
holy crap back here okay so oh okay I
got you where did that weird that where
did that vent leave cuz it refuses back
there I remember yeah yeah I don't make
sense now I should have remembered that
thank you guys for helping me out but
I'm gonna find out what's in this little
vent here maybe there's some goodies or
a monster hopefully some goodie oh it's
gun give me who did
oh I need I can pick that up don't don't
kill me bro don't blow me bro don't bomb
maker don't blow me bro
okay I'm good I'm good I'm okay
all right cool
I guess right here is back where I get
the sledgehammer here I think yeah I got
the sledgehammer over here and so now
I'm back here and the fuses were back in
a tunnel there there there it is right
there
haha that one why not yeah do I ride the
train or something go train go
haha I was right I was assuming that was
gonna be just totally wrong who's
running the who was trained
listen familiar
interesting
okay
yeah that's like a window to the Train
yeah sitting here like a fool like a
fool room feels like it was just a few
seconds ago I was traveling here no
think straight
yeah I got hit by a car woke up and
these things have been trying to kill me
sense uh-huh I mean what is actually
happening with me mom keeps telling me
to get to momen quiet or how would that
solve any crazy [ __ ] I've seen I can't
even contact the police
everything is just
but could it be that I'm just
hallucinating yes
no seriously am i yes or is there
something else oh you're crazy loony
cakes back in the doctor guy well he's
crazy
as it works a class mess
or is all this just not real yeah yeah
that one that one yes yes you are
I'm just you're not just very confused
that's correct so many questions but no
answers
42 I'll see what happens when I come
home
come whoa oh boy I didn't like that what
and doing
huh here want some who's that nobody
nobody huh who's there Oh what the hell
are you get down
then at me whomp there you one for good
man hell bro I'm not hot crotch like a
boss I he's been even over
anymore crash on the strain of the
mission goodies I don't know
well is going dark
whoa oh yay done Emma uneventful
that's gonna have reload Wow Wow
what the hell where'd you come from
just found out no where are you stay
there buddy oh hello oh hi gonna whop
donkey oh yeah I saw in a video I was
looking up how to do and I saw them fill
the way to sight down so I just get I've
been not sighting down for a long time
had any inclination point
I'm an idiot they go through the whole
game not even bother game sound the
ground there what is that you guys
that's ok I'll have one bonk for you
wait hold on I got more bombs
do they calm what what come on
looks like a foot oh the briefcase oh
wow yeah bad I wanna pick it into myself
laughs yeah well that wasn't even the
right save boner - uh Nonie all right I
I'm in I'm just gonna screw it I'm just
gonna run past
we'll grab everything I need oh this one
runs a stick around right no no there
you go
hi oh yeah go but stop yeah I guess I do
need to get my pistol out to shoot this
is a dark one that has nothing on not
scary not scary at all a lot of mobs
that just go em away there we go there
we go they're real oh I'm a diverse okay
so where the sheep all right pop up and
I crouch down like a boss i sight down
professional actually really hurt
what would be no fool
I probably got to kill the ones I can
run fast again right okay why not let oh
you just go stand there woosh
the loose one why in Simon's right mind
would you hear a crash and then go
backwards to get foot damn him get up
like ride by a foot
I don't you okay back back we say before
going live in 3 hi okay I'm on my feet
back I got one flip oh he said feet I
only had a foot hope that's ok buddy
what I just go over the edge
sit my back my back
ah come on Oh
hook whop get out get out there we go
there we go there
wow this is this orienting holy crap up
here get to this login jeez whoa who's
that I had best hurry I I suppose
Oh
go ha ha okay
I'll make it up
pump up come on crap on there stood up
for auction here
ah come on I wasn't just reminds me
about to die thank you
dammit Devin come on yeah there we are
there we go there we go there we come
out come out Canada that not it come out
come out now but now
come on kind of stand up please
oh no no don't fall over there
Mama's there I'm up I'm up I made it I
made it I made it
there we go bye-bye yay I'm victorious
find your way out of the forest
I seem to not be in a forest oh wait
that for and I got nothing set my fist
oh yeah huh that come in yeah
lantern yeah kick yeah nothing I guess
yeah I need sticks a got my fist I do
wield here oh yeah yeah look at this
no don't marijuana meth oh that's Jack
I'm pond you up I'm [ __ ] girl yeah with
this a grave awesome how to unlock
secret weapons all night long secret
women I don't even know how to read that
because it doesn't don't put there his
note still see uh no that was those old
eggs LT or now where the heck am I going
I get in this Shankar I guess I just got
to go through the forest where I was
is scary all right I'm running over time
but then again I don't think you all
mind right whenever they hit me a save
point that's when all okay there's
probably lots of hidden goodies in the
dark force here I think people are gonna
be too scared to go to live through not
me
there's lots of lantern obviously don't
want you to miss out ah here who wants
some oh there we go back yeah my way
gonna force through this board it up it
was that I thought I saw blue
no no hey ha ha what was that nothing
more water
nope ah I'm own deck deck go up I'll go
up door Oh Pippi argh
Oh what the hell saw that like bounce
man I'll be like that okay
puffy I kick new son of a [ __ ] yeah God
get the geometry whenever you like hit a
crevasse down it'll like fling you in a
different direction
ah there we go okay now don't fall off
falafels
ha ha I win y'all lose wonk get some ah
all right
oh no there's episode so long what are
you gonna do there's another one see
another one
dark dark eat dark Burke
aha where's the light see a life in o
lantern whatever whatever don't matter
it's all good
Oh God fell off the edge of the world
they wall up the other ways but not the
edge of the world what kind of safety
regulations is this I have no idea
primarily now tonight did it come from
there what the heck am I know all it's
broken here though maybe this is why I'm
so stupid
nope wall more wall hmm I'm told ah I'm
so lost scared and alone wish they give
me a safe place I don't want this to go
over 20 minutes whoa whoa whatever I
guess it can't be helped half life
always had a quick sale option
oh god just wanting a big circle
what the heck what the heck that what
how did I get past the broken part again
what
baloney I'm just following the wall okay
I can't follow the wall there's a wall
here
oh that's how I got turned around
because they oh okay broken part of the
wall he's and where I'm supposed to go
oh oh okay not that way either
what day ah so lost lost scared and
alone okay here we go here we go unless
this is where I was before if it is
whatever the edge of the world is there
but it's way out is another tangent I
thought I saw
oh I'm so turned around huh oh yeah yeah
yeah good damn it I want a save point
give me a frickin save point oh now I'm
lost in there just open to a pile of
branches F Oh [ __ ]
come on the hell there we go
on this what's where I just came in ah
it probably is you know probably where I
was supposed to go and then there was
nothing there I like wandered circles
for an hour there's nothing there's
nothing here either
I'll walled off forest Oh
kami okay alright maybe that's just like
telling me I'm not supposed to be back
now I'm over 20 minutes Bologna
alright if this goes on to 30 minutes
I'm just gonna cut it in two if it does
happen like that then you probably
already knew that you're watching the
second episode back I don't know I don't
know this is just [ __ ] hate getting
lost
had to be some way it had to be past the
broken wall somewhere maybe I should
bash down something it has to be past
this broken wall it just has to be okay
followed the wall and then led to
nothing because it's just walled off
it's the wood nothing there I follow the
wall and it leads to more walled off
piece of the wood follows the edge then
it leads to the edge of this city leave
this and here is where the Berlin Wall
is this is bull oh oh how long was that
there ah ah all right that's all the
time I got for this episode sorry it's
so long
maybe I'll just cut out the part where I
got missed but no you see all my feelers
so thank you so much for watching and I
will see you in the next part
bye bye